y la indignación de la gente una nueva
preocupación para el gobierno griego en
medio de los incendios que no dan tregua
lo que estamos contra el gobierno porque
han dejado que nuestro país se queme
pensando antes en el dinero que en las
personas protestamos porque destinan
millones para comprar aviones de guerra
y en la policía y dejan de lado a la
brigada de bomberos
más de 500 incendios agudizados por la
ola de calor han forzado a más de 2.000
residentes y turistas a evacuar entre
las regiones más afectadas están y ática
el primer ministro griego presentó sus
disculpas por el manejo que se le ha
dado a la situación y de cartaya el
nivel de destrucción especialmente en
uva y en ática nos parte el alma y soy
el primero en disculparme por las
debilidades que hemos tenido para
enfrentar la situación
entiendo perfectamente el dolor de los
ciudadanos que han visto sus casas y
propiedades quemarse y han tenido que
evacuar abruptamente o pozo pos en
efecto ha aprobado un presupuesto de 587
millones de dólares que será destinado a
ayudar a la gente que ha perdido sus
propiedades y pertenencias algunos
países de la comunidad europea han
enviado casi 1000 bomberos
nueve aeronaves y 200 vehículos en total
mientras el país espera dos aeronaves
más por parte de turquía y un avión por
parte de rusia ante las dificultades
locales por apagar los fuegos además las
autoridades helenas investigan si una
organización criminal provoco los
incendios